well
[Music]
hello how are you greetings by qualifying
friend with the most
outstanding headlines for today wednesday
october 28 two people are dead
after an alleged murder suicide in a
residence located near flamengo
and highway 95 the police say that it all
started  with an argument between couple the
mist saw that the man had a gun
she quickly took a child and left
the home while the man's wife was
unable to flee when the
special tactics team entered the
residence they found the husband with a
self-inflicted bullet  and the wife with a
gunshot wound she was taken to the
hospital where she was pronounced dead
a man is dead after a
police officer shot him last night
this happened around
half past eleven in a convenience store
located in pecos iker and agents
allege to have used their weapons
after the man reached for his weapon
investigators say that this same
subject had been  ado involved in a
shooting prior to this incident on the other
hand today a judge will hear the
arguments on the latest lawsuit
bet by the campaign of the president of
trump in the state of nevada his team and
the republicans here ask the state
to stop counting the  mailed ballots
in the las vegas area' the
lawsuit says it is not possible to have an
accurate count that checks the
signatures and verifies each of these
ballots however the secretary of
state says there is no evidence of
possible fraud and now  We turn to
the weather forecast today we will have a
sunny day with a maximum
reaching 74 degrees pleasant temperatures are expected
with clear
skies around 80 degrees for
everyone have a good day I am I came out Jaramillo
and this was them Neil in Spanish
[Music]